my name is Amry imakon and I wear a
number of different
hats I'm the author of she and control
now is Dr anarie imafidon Who's CEO and
co-founder of the stems which aims to
inspire and promote the next generation
of young women in science technology
engineering and maths uh and I do lots
of other different bits and
pieces the things that land in my inbox
people are like hey this is shle
countown have you heard of it you want
do numbers for a bit it's Dr anarie
idon very nice to have you here uh sure
Dr anarie is a Computing and Mathematics
genius who speaks five languages she got
two GCS while still at primary school
and is the president of the British
Science Association if it looks like
there's a plan then that's very
interesting for me to
[Music]
learn are you special I don't think
so I think I all I'll put it this way I
think I think everyone's special I just
don't think most folks have figured out
what that special is there's an element
of the way I've been able to take
opportunities and not be afraid to try
things and fail and succeed that maybe
is special like there are a lot of
things I can't do a lot of things I
don't
[Music]
remember yeah we've always only been
East never lived anywhere else like our
whole lives are centered around here I
just love the the difference like
there's just everybody is here and a
coexisting and enjoying life together
best place on
[Music]
Earth East London
hey
I am the eldest eldest of five
sadly you can't you don't choose it do
you no if you because if you're first
you the guinea pig I have many regrets
for that about 62 different
regrets so school was
frustrating in part because of the
repetition education is repetitive cuz
that's how how most folks learn and so
it was frust we we did this last year
and I remember us doing it last year and
it made sense last year so we can do
something else then it just turned into
I'm just going to sit and talk to T I'm
just going to sit and talk to Michael
I'm going to sit and talk to Rebecca iye
that oh she's finishes her work
early and then she gets into Mischief so
so we have to make sure that we see how
we can get rid of that mischievous
behaviors every child is gifted and
talented in ways and manners that I may
not know you may not know so let's find
out the talent of each child
outside it was exploration it was okay
let me like let's try this there's a
book that we found that's done this or
your cousins doing such and such subject
let's try that at one point I did Greek
lessons did Chinese lessons like
Mandarin there was just a lot of other
things that were that were free and
available outside and then also um I
like
devices we had a VCR player at home we
had lots of different things at home and
I was incredibly
curious that Curiosity and wanting to
understand how that works okay cool if
that works that way what do we do with
that okay so I was about four when I
took apart the VCR
player the thing was completely no
matter what button I pressed it gave me
something totally different how does it
work why does it always work how how did
it know and looking inside the cassette
tape you don't find what you're looking
for so yeah I'm going to go and have a
look inside the VCR player and maybe try
and lift it up and use other implements
Like Toy Soldiers
completely ruined my
VHS very expensive about 2 months wages
have you paid me back sorry Dad I have
yeah definitely I've definitely paid you
back so we used to go to um the computer
market so it was like secondhand stuff
so like cheaper a lot so a lot cheaper
like buying floppy discs or buying
motherboards or so then you get those
bits and pieces and try and think and
put them together and like build a whole
computer yeah she know bu her computer
was 9 or 10 I I give
[Music]
go when I graduated from Oxford the plan
was to go to the city and work it ended
up being kind of working on the tech for
the people that were in Tech I mean like
can said now but yeah I'd sit on the
computer all day for free he didn't
really need to pay me to do that um but
I enjoyed it because
I'm I've always been very curious and
always been like we can use technology
to solve problems and this was like a
ready supply of of problems that needed
to be solved with technology it's
because gender diverse teams make better
decisions I ended up being invited to
speak at a conference three and a half
thousand technical women in one
space and as someone that's always been
in technical spaces but never been in
female majority technical spaces it was
quite alarming for me quite life
affirming as well that wow
I didn't even know I was in this
minority it's almost like X-Men you're
like you have powers too um and so ended
up there and had a bit of a root to
Damascus moment of no you really are the
only girl in a lot of these places and
that's kind of not okay um and so I
ended up starting stets as a result of
being at that
[Music]
conference the dream is to work in the
space sector I am a first year Aerospace
undergraduate biochemistry and like
science to technology technology and
financial
markets it's it can be so isolating you
can feel so alone that actually just a
little bit of effort to get folks
together pays so many dividends for what
they do next for you know how they see
themselves the fact that they're not the
only girl in the entire world that's
ever done this and will ever do
it it's a frustration I do end up having
with events that I'm invited to these
days that are kind of manels right where
they've not been imaginative or thought
at all about who they have contributing
to the conversation and there's an email
I got literally last week that had the
same thing I had to write back and be
like is it me or do you not have a
single woman here on this email and
we're talking about Society in the
future and I'd have thought that maybe
we might have a couple of women in
society in the
future as we might want a little bit of
their experiences now to be reflected in
what we're discussing maybe just me I
don't know no in the stem curriculum at
GCSE and a level there is a lot of um
male names codified in so if we say like
I know Newton's Laws of Motion that
means Isaac Newton is inside the
curriculum is something that everyone
has to learn about and so we're wanting
to just counter the balance if every
time there's a male name you have a
female or otherwise name so whether it's
GPS and Dr Gladis West who did the mats
on the geostatic satellites whether it's
Teddy Lamar who was a Hollywood actress
and was incredibly Keen physicist and
ended up co-invention Wi-Fi or Bluetooth
Katherine Johnson who was a
mathematician in 1960s at Nasa did the
math by hand on early space travel or
space flights like a rosin Franklin the
women of bchy Park like there's so many
for every name that we have already in
the curriculum let's just put a little
bit of that Herer in alongside it and it
frustrates me that we still have a
national curriculum at least in this
country that doesn't mention the names
of any of these women and we have the
audacity to think that it's these dead
white dudes with beards are the only
people that have done anything of
note the
audacity how dare
[Music]
we at the moment with technology where
the uh entry point to what folks are
calling the fourth Industrial Revolution
so if you line up eight people five of
them are online or have a mobile device
which speaks a lot to the size and the
scale of what we're talking about but
the fact that it's not all
inclusive there are many reasons why
we're not all fluent in Tech there's
something of that definition of fluency
being able to understand is different to
being able to speak is different to
being able to uh write and it's used to
be reading writing and arithmetic and
now it's Reading Writing arithmetic and
R Digital
in Access there's access to
opportunities but there's also kind of
norms
stereotypes the one that's the most
frustrating is that barrier of who is
able and who is capable it's built on a
lot of very intentional kind of social
engineering centuries if not decades
back where if you're a young woman for
example in a classroom if it's a
technical if it's physics if it's
mathematical if it's engineering related
the idea that's something you might not
get just as a by virtue of who you are
and the fact that you it's really hard
for you to actually see that any other
woman has ever done maths or physics
engineering or technology before you all
of that then gets in the way of building
fluency that actually if we solve that
we would allow so many more people to
build that fluency and allow so many
more people to then have agency and also
solve so many
[Music]
problems I am the new chair of Udi music
Foundation
UD is here in East London and is all
about opening up opportunities in a way
that folks especially from this area
might not have seen or observed or be
aware that that is value that they can
bring to this space I'm re first came to
us and she was part of a scheme called
young board members roll it around roll
it wow energy intelligence Insight Drive
passion leadership that's how I describe
her
[Music]
the focus on music technology tends to
be embedded within the kind of
songwriting and production process we
need to build a skill set that is going
to make people's careers fit for purpose
she's a detail person so gets under the
Bonnet that detailed knowledge and
insight on how technology is changing
people's lives
visionary
aab or Aid lab is the artificial
intelligence design laboratory and as
far as we know it's the world's first
dedicated laboratory to Bringing
together design with artificial
intelligence the folks at Raw College of
Art like that that is really really
cutting edge a lot of folks don't get to
see that don't even imagine that a lot
of those things are possible or that
that would be a problem you want to
solve we look at transforming biowaste
into new materials and textiles I I
still love the technology I love the
problems that can be solved and I'm also
incredibly curious about things so Amry
is a member of our council at the RO
College of Art she's a great champion
and supporter of what we do whenever I
talk with Amry there's amazing curiosity
whereas being able to have it then
choose is is brilliant and why not be
inspired by Nature there's no HS B about
asking the questions the very considered
questions very thoughtful interventions
about what is the direction of research
policy why are we doing what we do also
about how do we make sure that
technology and stem is available for
everyone it represents everyone brings
everyone into that
conversation she's really someone who's
writing the future and enabling people
to be part of that future and write it
as well I think I'm very conscious that
I am a
young black woman from East London who's
had a very different upbringing from a
lot of people at these board tables who
spends a lot of time with young people
and so there's a lot of insights
experiences stories that I get to hear
that then can be fed back at those top
levels and so being able to bring that
to such a wide range of Institutions
excites me because that's the that's
kind of my my way of doing the systemic
change attack from the bottom and attack
from the top and that's kind of what I'm
doing and you've got to learn the system
to be able to change
it
hello hey let's do that your brand new
um Hometown I know have a new job and
everything yeah number 17 that's what
you need to get the tattoo or the
T-shirt or something or number one first
woman you know I think we'll get you a
number one t-shirt we'll make you a
number one t-shirt am I dancing inside
there's a minute table yes I'm dancing
inside because for a lot of folks if you
can't see it you can't be it I'm dancing
because if she's able to occupy that
position who else could occupy other
positions why have I met so many
directors of HQ classified
information only joking um you'll have
to ask them I have a hunch that in 20
years time when we look back on anarie
she will be seen as someone who has led
the charge I think she is destined for
even greater
things I think her dad wants her to be
prime minister let's
see I love to be remembered as being a
big part of that move or that change
towards who is technical what does
technical look
like I I have no idea what's next also
I'm still curious still the this is
basically me opening the VCR player but
just in a slightly different way I could
literally be sat here for
hours
[Music]
yay thanks for watching if you enjoyed
that be sure to check out these videos
next and if you haven't already hit the
Subscribe button and click the Bell to
get a notification each time we upload a
new video